welcome to round one action of the 2014  us Chess Championships here in st. Louis  but we saw some early upsets from the  younger players in the competition first  on the men's side Grandmaster ray Robson  crushed Sergey ehrenberg with a king  hunt that left the black pieces in  tatters that's just naturally my style  just to play with the initiative play  aggressively as much as possible and in  the women's championship first timer and  13 year old at Rita s warran played a  devastating finish against Victoria knee  when she attacked her King and caught  the King in a mating net I feel really  excited and no matter what the result is  I'll take it as a learning experience be  sure to join us for more from these  talented young stars here at the u.s.  championships at one p.m. Central here  in st. Louis at us chess champ calm